hey 42 here students in China tie their
hair to the ceiling to prevent
themselves from falling asleep while
studying welcome to RIF traces of cocoa
and nicotine found in some Egyptian
mummies have led to speculations that
ancient Egyptians may have traveled to
the new world
ie America the brain consumes 20% of the
body's energy yet it's only account for
2% of our total body weights the engine
of the BMW m5 is so quiet so the company
plays fake engine noises through the car
speakers to remind drivers of their cars
performance 1/4 of the bones in your
body are in your feet the tip of a
bullwhip moves so fast that when you
hear it crack the sound it makes is
actually a tiny sonic boom almost is the
longest word in the English language
with all the letters in alphabetical
order human fire bones are stronger than
concrete earth is the only planet in our
solar system not named after a god one
in five adults believes that aliens are
hiding on our planet disguised as humans
and finally there are no naturally
occurring blue foods even blueberries
are purple thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42